todo lo que hemos hecho de álgebra
lineal hasta este punto te puede parecer
que es la forma más difícil de hacer
cosas que ya sabes hacer ya has
trabajado con vectores y supongo que
algunos de ustedes los han visto en
clases de cálculo pre cálculo o física
pero en este vídeo espero mostrarles
algo que nunca han hecho en álgebra
lineal y que se sufre ha sido muy
difícil hacer si no hubiesen visto estos
vídeos comenzaría nuevamente con una
manera diferente de hacer algo que ya
saben hacer definiré un vector aquí y en
lugar de ponerlo esta vez con negrita lo
voy a dibujar con una flecha encima
definido un vector y le voy a poner aquí
su flecha o resaltar la negrita es lo
mismo y definiremos vectores en este
caso será un vector en r2 digamos que es
el vector 2 1 el vector 2 1 entonces en
la primera entrada tengo 2 viendo y
segunda entrada tengo 1
y bueno ahora lo que quiero ver es como
gráfico este vector en su posición
estándar camino 2 la derecha uno hacia
arriba y me quedaría este vector que
tengo aquí es el 0 0 y su punto final
sería el 21 hasta aquí vamos todo bien
pero en esta ocasión quiero ver qué es
lo que pasa con un cierto conjunto no
voy a tomar un conjunto llamado ese que
va a ser el conjunto de todos los
vectores que me resultan de multiplicar
a este vector por un número real así que
voy a multiplicar a este vector b por un
número real llamado cm y entonces esto
se escribe así sé por el vector b y se
va a existir en los números reales se es
un miembro de los números reales o se
existen los números reales y entonces
qué va a pasar con este conjunto que yo
tengo aquí con este conjunto que estoy
definiendo
supongamos los emmy que se vale 2 como
se vería dos veces este vector a bueno
antes de pintarlo en la gráfica que
tengo a la derecha voy a escribirlo aquí
si se vale 2 mejor déjenme escribirlo
así se vale 2
entonces me queda dos veces
y esto es lo mismo que 42 no me tengo
que multiplicar por 2 cada una de las
entradas como lo habíamos visto en los
vídeos pasados y entonces me queda este
vector que tengo aquí te das cuenta es
con lineal a este vector que yo tengo en
un inicio al vector de verde y además es
dos veces el vector de verde tienen la
misma dirección pero es el doble y si yo
tengo 1.5 por b pues esto me quedaría 2
por 1.5 que es 3 y 1 por 1.5 que es 1.5
y me va a dar este vector que tengo aquí
este aquí
no es para acá este son tres sub o 1.5 y
me queda este vector de amarillo que es
te das cuenta tienen también la misma
dirección y lo único que cambia es que
es el vector de de x 1.5 veces su
magnitud pero se puede ser cualquier
número real puede ser por ejemplo punto
0 0 1 si fuera este pequeño número de
aquí pues me saldría un pequeño vector
con la misma dirección pero con una
magnitud muy pequeña y si fuera negativo
pues entonces iría hacia abajo empieza
en el mismo punto tiene una magnitud
pequeña pero va hacia abajo y esto ya te
da la idea de que entonces podemos tener
y multiplicando a este vector cualquier
sé que se te ocurra 1.300.000 y lo que
sea y como existen los números reales
también nos estamos refiriendo a los
números negativos por ejemplo - p - un
millón etcétera
y bueno si gráfica mos todos déjenme
hacerlo con calma si gráfica mos todos
los vectores de este conjunto
estamos graficando una línea recta te
das cuenta y bueno esta es una nueva
forma de escribir una línea recta y
bueno a este conjunto se le llama el
conjunto de los vectores con lineales
vectores con lineales porque todos van a
ser la misma dirección esto es lo que
pasa cuando yo multiplico por una
constante en los números reales y más
aún fíjate bien en esto si yo tengo que
el vector d es el vector 21 estamos
hablando del plano de re 2 yo puedo ver
a este vector 21 como un punto te das
cuenta como el punto 21 x igualados y
igual a 1 por lo tanto a esto se le
conoce como una posición como el vector
posición y ahora fíjate bien si yo tomo
el conjunto de todos los vectores co
lineales realmente lo que estaría
dibujando es
toda una línea recta toda una línea
recta que cumple con lo siguiente cumple
que este punto este punto b estaría en
el vector y además que tiene una
pendiente de un medio porque recordemos
2 en x por cada uno de ella y entonces
me queda 1 aquí 2 acá y entonces lo que
quiero decirte es que este conjunto te
va a dibujar una línea recta y por lo
tanto es otra definición nueva de línea
recta para la definición antigua que
nosotros veíamos con una pendiente de
una ordenada al origen en esta ocasión
estamos hablando de cómo sabemos o cómo
podemos obtener una línea recta dado un
vector y es con este conjunto de
vectores con lineales porque la
representación de todos estos vectores
es decir de una constante multiplicada
por un vector original es una línea
recta que además date cuenta que pasa
por el origen y fíjate la importancia de
tener a los vectores en su posición
estándar porque yo podía tomar un vector
que no estuviera su posición estándar
por ejemplo este y a partir de aquí
definir todo lo que era el conjunto de
los vectores co lineales y me ha salido
otra línea recta sin embargo la
importancia de tomar el vector en
posición estándar es que estamos tomando
una línea recta
este es un vector posición este es un
conjunto de vectores kong lineales y
entonces nos damos cuenta que dibujan a
una línea recta y que por lo tanto esta
es una nueva definición de lo que es una
recta y bueno fíjate también que este
vector de lo que me marcaba era la
pendiente por lo tanto vamos a
escribirlo este vector de aquí lo que me
marca es la pendiente de esta recta que
estoy dibujando ahora bien qué pasa si
queremos una recta que no esté en el
origen es decir supongamos que lo que
queremos es una recta que está en otro
punto que no sea el cero cero así que
vamos a tomar un punto cualquiera y voy
a tomar este de aquí que parece ser que
es el 2,4 cómo puedo yo dibujar una
recta paralela o cómo puedo escribir yo
una recta paralela que pase por el punto
24 ojo lo que quiero es una recta
paralela a esta recta que está dibujada
por mi conjunto es y bueno lo primero
que voy a hacer es tomarme un vector el
vector que esté en posición estándar y
que tenga como punto final el punto 2,4
y bueno pues eso es muy fácil es el
vector
24 al cual le voy a llamar x x vector va
a ser igual al 24 entonces lo que voy a
buscar es toda una recta que sea
paralela a nutrexpa que me salió en el
conjunto s es decir a mi recta que me
sale de multiplicar una constante por el
vector de lo que voy a querer hacer es
dibujar una recta paralela a esta recta
pero que pase por el punto 2 como a 4
así que esta recta crece para ambos
lados y lo que quiero es que estas dos
rectas sean paralelas ahora bien como
escribo la ecuación o como escribo un
conjunto que me diga esta línea azul que
estoy dibujando aquí es decir lo que
quiero encontrar es un conjunto de
vectores que a graficar los me dé en
esta línea azul que tengo aquí
bueno pues fíjate bien qué pasa si yo
agarro un vector cualquiera de este
vector que tengo en mi conjunto con
lineal de vectores ya ese vector le sumo
mi nuevo vector x pues entonces voy a
obtener un punto de esta línea azul si
te das cuenta ahora si yo agarro otro
vector de este conjunto de vectores con
lineales voy a suponer que voy a agarrar
este de aquí cuál es este vector que
tengo aquí y si te das cuenta estamos
el punto menos 24 es decir es menos dos
veces el vector original si te das
cuenta menos dos veces el vector
original me da el vector menos 42 y ya
que tengo este vector de aquí ahora le
voy a sumar el vector x que es el vector
24 y bueno tomé una constante arbitraria
que en este caso fue menos 2 y ahora le
voy a sumar el vector x es decir que al
menos dos veces este vector si yo le
sumó el vector x a donde voy a dar
fíjate bien tengo que caminar 12 hacia
la derecha y 4 hacia arriba 2 la derecha
4 hacia arriba y qué creés doy a otro
punto de esta línea azul que tengo aquí
que era mi línea paralela por lo tanto
se me ocurre que ya puedo definir cómo
se puede representar esta línea azul que
es paralela original en un conjunto
porque si te das cuenta cualquier vector
que yo tome en este conjunto ese y
después le sume x me va a dar un punto
de esta línea paralela y si tengo una
infinidad de puntos porque tengo una
infinidad de vectores en este conjunto
ese por lo tanto voy a obtener toda la
línea azul a ver vamos a escribirlo él
le va a ser mi conjunto de los vectores
que al vector x le voy a sumar
una constante pero en esta ocasión a la
constante le voy a poner t porque se
llaman ecuaciones paramétricas y las
ecuaciones paramétricas casi siempre
esta constante se le pone t por lo tanto
le voy a sumar t veces me vector b
tevez es mi vector b y si te das cuenta
el segundo sumando es lo mismo que mi
conjunto ese y solamente hay que definir
qué te existen los números reales o en
su dado caso este es un miembro de los
números reales y entonces voy a correr
arte por todos los números reales este
conjunto de aquí lo que me va a dar son
todos los puntos que yo tengo en mi
línea azul que yo quería dibujar y ya te
la podemos variar puede valer menos 2
menos 100 menos 50 23 me llevan a lo que
sea y todos estos vectores tarde o
temprano me van a dar puntos de esta
línea azul que tengo aquí arriba y si te
das cuenta ya con esto podremos escribir
cualquier recta paralela a esta recta
original que yo tenía en un principio si
yo tomo un vector en mi conjunto de
vectores con lineales ya ese le sumó el
vector en coordenadas cartesianas me dé
el punto por donde quiera pasar mi recta
paralela entonces ya tengo
y recta paralela definida por esta
ecuación y bueno seguramente tú me vas a
decir oye presto es una definición poco
obtusa yo en mis clases de preparatoria
aprendí una forma mucho más fácil de ver
una recta las rectas todas las revistas
las veíamos de la forma ordenada al
origen es decir que es igual a mx más
bien esto lo veías en tus clases de
geometría analítica y recuerda que la
pendiente por ejemplo la definidas como
el cambio en x / el cambio y además
necesitabas un punto y es igual a mx más
ven y me vas a preguntar bueno si ya
tengo esta definición donde aquí tengo
la pendiente ya y también tengo en donde
corta el eje de las 'íes' entonces
porque tengo que aprenderme ahora esta
otra definición además esta definición
es mucho más obtusa y la respuesta es
que esta definición es mucho más general
que la definición que viste en prepa
déjame ponerlo aquí esto es mucho más
general que todo lo que viste en prepa
porque si te das cuenta
esto funciona bastante bien en r2
cualquier recta cuando cartesiano la
podemos ver de la forma es igual a mx
más ven pero si yo quiero irme a un
espacio en r3
en cualquier dimensión ya no va a ser
tan difícil que yo encuentro una recta
viéndola desde la forma es igual
y por lo tanto si yo utilizo esta nueva
definición de este conjunto que te acabo
de dar la suma de un vector más una
constante por otro vector éste te va a
dar cualquier recta en cualquier
dimensión y es a eso a lo que me refiero
con que sea mucho más general cualquier
recta en cualquier dimensión se puede
ver de esta forma en este conjunto así
que vamos ser el último ejemplo que me
queda en r2 vamos a tomar los dos
vectores en esta ocasión me voy a tomar
un vector a un vector bent así que vamos
a definir los vamos a bautizarlos aquí
abajo voy a decir que el vector a base
del vector y vamos a tomar el vector 2-1
a base del vector cuyas componentes son
el 21 y bueno vamos a dibujarlo primero
en su posición estándar 2 a la derecha 1
hacia arriba y este director a perfecto
ahora me voy a tomar otro vector
director bent y mi vector b lo voy a
definir o lo voy
utilizar como aquel que tiene como
componentes el 0 y el 3 el vector b va a
ser el 0 3 y entonces ya que tengo este
vector b también lo voy a graficar aquí
en este plano cartesiano y dice no
camino nada a la derecha subo tres
unidades y obtengo este vector de que
tengo aquí ahora este va a ser mi vector
ven y me pregunta en esta ocasión va a
ser la siguiente ya que tengo el vector
am y ya que tengo el vector de me
recuerda que estamos hablando en un
plano cartesiano en r2 como puedo yo
encontrar a la recta que pasa por el
punto final de b y por el punto final de
am es decir voy a juntar estos dos
puntos que tengo aquí tanto a éste como
a este y voy a hacer pasar una línea
recta por estos dos puntos y mi pregunta
es como encuentro yo la recta que pasa
por estos dos puntos o mejor aún como
encontramos el conjunto que me defina a
todos los puntos de esta recta de verde
que tengo aquí así que déjame dibujar un
poquito mejor
a más o menos queda sin y bueno ahora
vamos a utilizar todo el conocimiento
que hemos creado en este vídeo cómo
puedo encontrar yo un vector
eso estaría genial encontrar un vector
que esté en esta recta porque si
encuentra un vector que esté en esta
recta y lo multiplicó por alguna
constante y esta constante la varió en
todos los números reales entonces me va
a dar esta recta que yo tengo aquí y
bueno la pregunta es cómo encuentro y un
vector sobre esta recta y la respuesta
es fijémonos en la diferencia de b con
am si nosotros nos fijamos en la
diferencia de b konaté acuerdas que se
alían pues sería justo este vector que
estoy dibujando aquí este de aquí es
venenosa o dicho de otra manera nos
preguntábamos por el vector tal que la
agregarle a nos daba el vector b
es decir b menos a y bueno ya que tengo
es el vector aquí de menos amp entonces
si yo lo multiplicó por cualquier
constante me va a dar la gráfica de esta
línea verde que yo tengo aquí porque voy
a pasar por todos estos puntos estirando
y encogiendo a este vector y además
girándolo para el otro lado por lo tanto
voy a escribirlo aquí cualquier
constante te recuerda que estamos
hablando de una forma para
cuando hablamos de formas paramétricas
ponemos a la constante ua la variable
tema y es que cuando oigas ecuaciones
paramétricas te aconsejo que siempre
pongas a la variable t que multiplica al
vector b - ar
pero cuidado hay que tener mucho cuidado
porque el vector menos ha visto desde su
posición estándar me quedaría este
vector que estoy dibujando aquí porque
recuerdan que si yo no le pongo nada a
este vector b entonces me lo va a
dibujar en su posición estándar n va a
salir una recta paralela a la recta que
yo quiero pero qué pasa por el origen y
al final no es la recta que yo quiero
recuerda que cuando vemos a un vector en
su forma o en su posición estándar
estamos refiriéndonos a un vector cuyo
punto inicial es el origen y bueno
entonces me pregunta es cómo puedo
escribir la ecuación de esta línea verde
que era mi problema original ya encontré
una parametrización de la ecuación
paralela que pasa por el origen ahora lo
que me quiero preguntar es como
encuentro la línea verde que no va a
pasar por el origen pero esto es muy
sencillo vamos a usar lo segundo que
vimos el día de hoy si a esta línea
amarilla yo le sumó el vector b en este
caso después de variar t por todo
números reales me va a dar ya por fin el
conjunto de puntos que su gráfica me van
a dar la línea de verde es decir que
esto dado te en los números reales es
una parametrización por fin de esta
línea de verde el vector de más tevez es
el vector de menos a pero lo bueno es
que no solamente le puedo tomar el
vector b a esta línea de verde porque si
te das cuenta el vector a también pasa
por esta línea por lo tanto podemos
tomar otro conjunto el cual sea el
vector am y al vector a le vamos a
agregar lo mismo
tevez es el vector de menos a y me va a
dibujar la misma recta de verde que yo
tengo aquí a la derecha porque porque
tanto el vector de como el vector a
cuando yo le sumo a esta recta paralela
me van a dar a la recta de verde y me
van a dar todos los puntos de la recta
de verde por lo tanto aquí ya tengo dos
definiciones esta es mi primera
representación y esta otra es mi segunda
representación sea que le sume el vector
a o sea que le sumó el vector bien pero
bueno está en una forma muy general y
muy abstracta seguramente tú vas a decir
es que no entiendo nada así que vamos a
ponerle los valores de ahí debe para que
te quede mucho más claro
al final voy a tomar la definición que
está aquí arriba pero es lo mismo
tomarme la definición de arriba o de
abajo es decir sumarle el vector de al
principio sumar del vector al principio
es justo lo mismo porque tenemos dos
definiciones análogas y por lo tanto voy
a definirlo con el conjunto de arriba a
ver la línea va a estar definida por el
vector de voy a tomarme el primero la
definición de arriba y el vector de era
el vector 03 ya esto le voy a sumar
tevez es el vector b - pero quién es el
vector b menos anp
parémonos en b y restamos a cero menos
dos me queda menos dos y tres menos uno
me queda dos positivos ahora sí ya que
le pusimos números la línea de verde
está representada por este conjunto que
es el conjunto del vector 0 3 más de
veces el vector menos 2 2 y t existen
los reales y bueno si te das cuenta esta
definición va a depender del parámetro t
pero en nuestro plano cartesiano está en
equis y entonces como por un contrario
una representación paramétrica de esta
línea que yo tengo aquí si te das cuenta
nuestra primera coordenada nuestra
primera componente siempre le hemos
llamado que es la componente x porque
representa un valor en x mientras que la
segunda componente representa un valor
en sí es la componente bien ahora bien
si yo quisiera encontrar una forma de
representar esta misma línea recta pero
en dos componentes una componente que
dependa solamente de xy dt y otra
componente que dependa solamente de jay
y de tm es decir una representación
paramétrica esta sería otra forma de
escribir a esta misma línea recta pero
tal vez una forma mucho más clásica y
más metida en ecuaciones esta es la
coordenada x ésta es la coordenada que
la coordenada james y como podríamos
escribir una ecuación paramétrica o un
conjunto de ecuaciones paramétricas que
me definan esta línea verde que yo tengo
aquí pues bueno si ésta es la coordenada
en x y está la coordenada en x entonces
basta pensar que esto es decir justo
esto que voy a atrapar ahorita va a ser
lo que está en x entonces me quedaría
que x es igual a 0
a veces recuerda que este es un
parámetro más el parámetro t x menos 2
es decir menos 2 temps y que se va a ver
de la siguiente forma que es igual a
tres más dos veces el parámetro t hay
que multiplicar dos por el parámetro t
que está aquí afuera de este vector y
aquí encuentra una cuestión paramétrica
déjenme limpiar estas ecuaciones x es
igual a menos 2 temps y es igual a 3 más
2 t2 t3 y ya con esto tengo una
representación paramétrica si tú has
visto los vídeos de ecuaciones
paramétricas te vas a dar cuenta que
estas dos ecuaciones paramétricas me
grafican esta línea de verde que era mi
problema original y bueno yo sé que el
vídeo se está poniendo un poco largo y
tal vez estás un poco cansado pero para
mí es de suma importancia que veas un
ejemplo con algo que no tenga que ver
con nada que hayas visto en tus clases
de preparatoria en este caso voy a
tratar con vectores pero no en un plano
cartesiano no en r2 en esta vez voy a
tomar vectores en r3 es decir me voy a
tomar de vectores con tres dimensiones
así que vamos a tomarme el primer vector
el cual voy a llamar p 1 y va a ser
vector a menos 12 y 7 este es mi primer
vector y me voy a tomar otro vector
llamado p subíndice 2 y este vector p
subíndice 2 va a ser mi vector 0 3 y 4 0
3 y 4 bueno ahora lo que quiero
preguntar es cómo encuentro la línea
recta o el conjunto de los puntos de la
línea recta que pasa por estos dos
puntos en r3 es decir en el espacio aquí
ya no estoy utilizando las coordenadas
en r2 y por lo tanto como lo haríamos
bueno utilizando lo mismo que vimos hace
rato la línea es un conjunto que está
definido por cualquiera de esos dos
puntos no voy a tomar mejor el punto
inicial el punto uno más
tves es recuerda que estamos hablando de
ecuaciones paramétricas y que estos dos
son vectores se me olvidó ponerle la
línea en china más tres veces porque
estamos hablando de ecuaciones
paramétricas y te puede serte de tiempo
o cualquier parámetro lo vamos a tomar
como una variable en los números reales
y te va a multiplicar a la diferencia
entre 1 y ps2 al final podremos tomarnos
cualquier diferencia de peso
1 2 o en su dado caso peso el índice 2 -
p subíndice 1 pues al multiplicar los x
te van a generar toda la recta y además
recuerda que tenemos que escribir que te
está definido en los números reales
entonces tal que te existen los números
reales y bueno pues ahora lo que se me
ocurre es ponerles números a esta
ecuación por lo tanto vamos a ver
quiénes p1 y qué es la diferencia entre
p1 y p2 primero vamos a calcular la
diferencia entre peso 20 c 1 y p
subíndice 2 y esto me va a quedar menos
10 me da menos 12 menos 3 me da menos 1
y 7 menos 4 edad 3
esto es p 1 - p 2 y lo que te decía es
muy importante también podíamos tomar la
diferencia entre peso índice 2 y peso 15
1 pero como te lo vamos a recorrer con
todos los números reales pues también va
a tomar los valores negativos ya brasil
como voy a definir la línea que va a
pasar por los puntos cuyas coordenadas
equivalen a las componentes de p1 y p2
bueno tomemos primero p subíndice 1 y es
el menos 12 y 7 ya esto hay que sumarle
tevez es la diferencia entre peso fuente
1 y peso
pero ya lo calculamos esto era menos 1 1
y 3 y recuerda tal que te existen los
números reales esto es importante la
anotación de conjuntos que existe en
todos los números reales y bueno no sé
qué tan difícil sea poder graficar esto
vamos a intentar graficar esto y para
esto lo que necesito es bajar un poco la
pantalla y voy a intentar hacer un
espacio entonces déjenme bajar un poco
la pantalla así que como estamos en tres
dimensiones necesitamos tres ejes no
solamente dos este de aquí va a ser mi
eje de las setas este de aquí es mi eje
de las equis y como estamos en el
espacio me falta el eje de las 10 así
que voy a dibujarlo este de aquí va a
ser mi eje de las 10 perfecto ya tengo
mis tres ejes ya estoy hablando 9
espacio y cómo podría yo graficar esta
línea recta que tengo aquí bueno lo
primero que se me ocurre hacer es
escribir estas ecuaciones en forma
paramétrica es decir buscar las
ecuaciones para x para ella y para zeta
vistos conforme el parámetro tema
entonces x sería igual a menos 1 este
primer valor me va a quedar x es igual a
menos 1 más
tevez es más té con amarillo más té
veces menos uno o dicho de otra manera
menos 1 t bueno esta es mi primera
ecuación paramétrica y esta es mi
ecuación paramétrica para x ahora vamos
a fijarnos en yemen que va a ser igual a
esta ecuación parametría que estoy
dibujando aquí y es igual a 2 + menos 1
por t esto me queda menos 1 t y como
tenemos 3 componentes en esta ocasión y
además tenemos tres ejes ordenados pues
ahora también vamos a tener una ecuación
paramétrica para z 7 es igual a 7 más 3
veces este transporte es 3 t 773 veces
temps y ya tengo mis 3 ecuaciones
paramétricas en esta ocasión las cuales
me dibujan una línea recta pero ten
cuidado porque aquí está lo distinto de
lo que habías visto en sus clases de
geometría analítica porque en el plano
cartesiano si tomamos una ecuación de la
forma x más igual a una constante me
dibuja una línea recta pero en esta
ocasión si yo tomo algo de la forma x
más jay-z igual una constante no es una
línea recta no está tan fácil dibujar a
una línea recta así que déjenme
escribirlo x massieu más 7 igual acá
esto no es una recta en r3 esto de aquí
me va a dibujar un plano y más aún la
única forma en la que yo pueda dibujar
una línea recta en r3 es con tres
ecuaciones paramétricas como las que
tenemos aquí así que si por ejemplo
quiero describir el camino del vuelo no
sé de una mosca en r3 en línea recta
tiene que ser con ecuaciones
paramétricas y entonces aquí te presento
por fin a las ecuaciones paramétricas
que van a describir a una línea recta en
r3 y solamente de esta manera puedes
escribir una línea recta en r3 y bueno
espero que este vídeo te sea bastante
útil porque acabamos de ver cosas que
nunca habías visto en tu vida además
estamos viendo cómo definir una línea
recta cualquier línea recta conforman
vectores y recuerda que lo importante de
esto es que los vectores te hablan de
una forma general es decir que si
nosotros queremos tomar una línea recta
en 50 dimensiones lo podemos hacer
utilizando vectores